i started another
caption contest with this picture which
i'll tell you about in just a moment
and i was surprised within a matter of
days
i had over 50 comments and some of them
are actually you know quite good
and so you see the top 10 here
in this video along with a few others
that i aggregated
together and there is some backstory as
always
with this i'm going to play the clip
that it's from it's from a class session
that i did
at marist college when i first started
teaching there
teaching introduction to philosophy and
ethics and this
was from a class on aristotle's nick
mccann ethics
book one where we're talking about what
happiness is what makes
people happy and back then i used to
carry some money around in my
wallet typically i don't do that too
much anymore
and i had two one dollar bills i
actually had four
dollars total in my wallet and i
took them out to illustrate a few points
as you can see in this clip here
i mean you know we've done this before
right take out these dollar bills
today i happen to have four of them
which is almost enough to like you know
get you a meal in the cafeteria so
yeah they sound really nice um
no there's better sounding things oh
yeah feels so good
now there's there's nicer feeling things
right like somebody said
who is it that you build a house out of
money uh or you could put
ins use it for installations yeah um
you're not gonna get much insulation on
this but i suppose if you get a lot of
these
probably be cheaper just to buy
insulation though
there's not a lot you can get out of
this by itself
i mean you know if i'm lonely i can look
at george
oh he's looking back at me no i don't
feel so alone
i'd be nuts right
so as i said we had a lot of really
funny
entries in the caption contest we also
got three
here that are all you know aggregated
together
because they're all basically making the
same
joke um how it feels to receive the 1400
stimulus check you know i mean if you
think about what would be
involved in that i'd actually have to go
to an atm and
somehow get one dollar bills out of it
that i could rub
on my my face but it you know it's
pretty funny nonetheless
but now we get into the really funny
quips
so here's one that is actually one of my
favorites
phthalates every olive harvest and
if you know anything about the story of
thales he's the guy who said that
everything is water so
a lot of people make fun of him ah
stupid thalis and he actually got made
fun of a good bit in his own time
because he was constantly
looking at the sky and you know fell
into a drainage ditch and
but he managed to corner the market
on a commodity that was needed
for for all of harvesting namely olive
presses he knew it was going to be a
great year so he went around and he
bought up all the olive presses in his
his native area
and made a ton of money apparently so
you know who's to say you can't make
money with philosophy right
uh here's another good one this is from
you know marxism
taking commodity fetishism to a whole
new level
it's good joke it's a good joke in part
because it's
like turning marks on his head in some
respects
sort of like marx supposedly turned
hegel on his head because commodity
fetishism
would be for commodities right so
not the dollar bill itself
i suppose you could say that it falls
into that in some respect but
generally we think of it as the
commodities themselves being the thing
that gets turned into
a fetish right here's another good one
um also from marx
[Music]
here we go uh demonstrating marks cash
distributed equally to both cheeks
so you know marx has that from each
according to their ability to each
according to their needs
cheeks are pretty equal so if they need
dollar bills
for any thing i guess it's fair that
each of them
gets their own dollar bill that's kind
of nice isn't it um
here's another great pun right here
making the real
you die money right and and this is this
is particularly apt because
aristotle's notion of happiness as we
know is eudaimonia
that's the greek term for it and you
know
you die money is a great way to
reframe that although of course the
lesson was that money itself isn't going
to get you what you want
another punting one here's hegel's
philosophy of right
right down to the bottom line so that's
that's a good one
i think the puns need to be you know apt
short and right on target in order to be
really funny here's another hegel
related one
and this this kind this one requires a
little bit more explanation the noble
consciousness
after flattering the monarch well what
does that mean right well that's part of
the phenomenology the spirit
section where you've got this noble and
base
consciousness and the noble
consciousness gets revealed as being a
bit
hypocritical that it has to engage in
some flattery with
the monarch and you know money isn't
supposed to matter except to the base
consciousness but it but it turns out
that it might to the noble consciousness
as well
here's another good one never dare a
philosopher to put his money where his
mouth is now that's not you know
actually going in my mouth
but pretty close to at the cheeks right
and i suppose you could say you're
putting your money where your mouth is
when you're engaging in an explanation
of money where you're rubbing
uh dollar bills on your cheeks to
illustrate a point right
um here's another rather funny one
although you know completely off base in
many respects sadler wiping the tears of
his failing students with their tuition
money
it's kind of a funny thing to think
about i
you know i would look at the how much
things cost students in terms of tuition
money at most of the places that i
taught
generally one or two of the students in
the class
was basically paying my
my salary or my wages for teaching
that class and all the rest was going to
the rest of the
school because you know as an adjunct
you don't get paid that much i got paid
pretty well in some places like marist
did a good job marquette did a good job
but even so so much of that tuition
money is go
is like just being funneled into
everything else in the university
and you know the other funny thing is i
don't actually fail that many students
generally when students fail my classes
it's because they're
not showing up and not doing the work i
set my classes up in such a way as to
take students who are
at risk and then get them you know to
to perform everybody's measured on
performance not on
you know arbitrary measures or something
like that but it is kind of a funny
thought nonetheless
now here's a good one so herbert spencer
looked something like this right and and
if
i'm going to show you a picture of
spencer in just a moment so you can see
that indeed he kind of did look like
that because of his sideburns
the irony is who teaches herbert spencer
i don't think anybody i mention him from
time to time because i've actually read
him
but i i've met very few people who've
actually
read him or even know who he is so that
was that's a pretty good
comment right there here's a picture of
spencer
look at those sideburns man that is
quite a
hairstyle isn't it here is the last one
i think this is a particularly good one
to go out on you may not like it but
this is what peak performance
looks like i think many of you are
familiar with that meme
and okay it's kind of cool to get sucked
into that meme
right the idea is that you pick
something that's definitely
not peak performance and you put it out
there
and so you know a philosophy professor
rubbing two one dollar bills
on his cheeks to illustrate a point
probably not
peak performance even in like the field
of competitive
philosophy or something like that but um
it's a good joke nonetheless so that's
the captions this time around
um i'll be doing more of these in the
future so
you can stay tuned to my channel they're
always going to be
in the um tab for a community
so if you're you know if you've like
turned your notifications off you
probably want to turn them on
so that you see things like this when
they pop up
if you want to get in on it if you just
want to be a spectator well then you
don't need to do that so
that's it for this one
you